bienvenidos de nuevo aquí está el mejor
intento de graficar el siguiente
problema y más o menos lo que está
diciendo es mejor voy a leerlo el
experimento de biología de raúl
involucra a 12 hamsters y un laberinto
cada hámster tiene la oportunidad de
recorrer el laberinto la primera vez de
práctica para después ser cronometrado
es decir vamos a meter a hámster en un
laberinto en una primera vez para que
conozcan el laberinto ya partir de ahí
cada vez que los metamos de nuevo va a
contar como una de las prácticas y vamos
a cronometrar en segundos cuánto tiempo
tarda el hámster en salir del laberinto
la gráfica de dispersión siguiente esta
de aquí muestra los tiempos que le tomó
a cada hámster salir del laberinto aquí
están los tiempos y el correspondiente
número de prácticas que cada ratón ha
realizado con base a los datos cuál de
las siguientes gráficas compara de
manera adecuada la relación entre tema
que es el número de segundos que le
lleva al hámster salir del laberinto
qué es el número de prácticas es decir
esencialmente lo que estamos buscando es
saber quién es este
bp quiénes tdp una función que dependa
del número de prácticas y que me dé el
tiempo y lo que queremos hacer es cuadro
y las siguientes funciones compara de
manera adecuada estas dos variables y
bueno primeramente si tú ves la gráfica
puedes concluir que estos hamsters no
aprendieron mucho pues cuando tuvieron
más prácticas es decir pese a que
aumentaron el número de prácticas uno
dos tres cuatro cinco los hámsters
siguen haciendo el recorrido más o menos
en el mismo tiempo y entonces podemos
intentar trazar una recta que se ajuste
a esta curva y la recta pues se verían
más o menos así sería una venta más o
menos como por aquí la cual sería una
recta constante y lo que nos está
diciendo es que el promedio del tiempo
que se tarda cada uno de los hámsters en
salir del laberinto es pues más o menos
como 45 44 45 44 segundos o dicho de
otra manera la curva
qué más está ajustando a estos puntos
pues es un promedio de estos puntos que
es esta línea y esta línea tiene como
ecuación tdp igual a 44 tdp igual a 44 y
bueno aunque estos cánceres no
aprendieron mucho acerca de conseguir
del laberinto espero que estos
estudiantes de los vídeos del st
mientras más aumentamos la práctica de
los ejercicios de este examen más
aprendan porque con estos hamsters no es
así y bueno de hecho este es el inciso
am el instó a me dice ttp igual a 44
vamos a ver los otros incisos para que
te das cuenta que realmente no tiene
nada que ver el inciso b me dice tvp tvp
es igual a p y bueno pues eso
esencialmente sería una recta como ésta
una recta identidad y bueno a la recta
identidad no me está aproximando a lo
que está pasando aquí arriba entonces ve
en definitiva no es el inciso c m dice
que te dé p es igual a 44
44 pero esto está de locos 44 ps ver y
algo así sería una recta con la super
pendiente y esto no me están
relacionando estos puntos por lo tanto
el inciso c tampoco es mi respuesta
correcta el inciso d me dice ttp tdp es
igual
ap entre 44 de entre 44 cosas que
tampoco es cierto aquí estoy hablando de
una recta con pendiente 1 entre 44 tengo
una pendiente super pequeña sería algo
muy parecido a esto y esto ni siquiera
tiene que ver con estos puntos por lo
tanto ésta tampoco sería mi respuesta
correcta y el inciso en el inciso y abs
de él me dice que te dé p es igual a p
más 44 y esto tampoco es cierto esto es
una recta parecida a la recta identidad
solamente que corta el eje las 'íes' en
el valor de 44 sería una recta más o
menos como está para arriba la cual
tampoco es cierta entonces pues esto
tampoco es mi respuesta correcta en mi
respuesta correcta es el inciso a
tvp 44 muy bien vamos a resolver ya el
último problema de la sección 8 del
examen 3 el problema 16 así que vamos a
ponerlo por acá el último problema 16
que por cierto también tienen una figura
la figura siguiente
veamos tomemos un color para hacer
muchos rectángulos tenemos un rectángulo
más o menos así un rectángulo más o
menos así después por aquí tengo una
línea parecida a esta otro del término
parecido a éste después tengo otro
rectángulo que la mitad parecido a este
algo así y después aquí tengo otros
rectángulos tengo el rectángulo parecido
a este algo así después tengo otro
rectángulo como éste muy parecidos
algo así después otro como éste bueno es
un dibujo muy parecido a este y qué
datos nos dan y nos dicen que este lado
mide w este lado mide el este de aquí
mide w a más o menos me quedo este lado
también de w bueno aquí este parece
estar un poco más grande pero en el
problema realmente dice que vale w
y aquí éste también vale w se parecen un
poco no quedó tan mal este lado mide l y
este lado mide l muy bien y lo que me
preguntan es la figura que se muestra a
continuación es decir ésta está
compuesta de rectángulos este patrón
este mismo patrón de 1 2 3 4 5 tenemos 5
rectángulos rectángulos
rectángulos le voy a poner 5 rectángulos
l w este patrón de 5 rectángulos el de w
lo vamos a usar para cubrir por completo
una región de 12 unidades de largo y 10
de ancho vamos a dibujar la tengo una
región parecida a ésta la cual va a
tener 12 unidades de ancho por 10 de no
al revés a 32 unidades de largo aquí va
a tener 12 unidades mientras que por
esta parte va a tener 10 unidades de
ancho y esta le vamos a llenar de puras
figuras con este patrón y lo que nos
preguntan precisamente es cuántos
rectángulos de l x w
cuántos de estos rectángulos necesitamos
para llenar esta región y bueno lo
primero que se me ocurre es ver si
existe alguna relación entre w y l
por aquí no tengo mucho pero por acá
tengo que dos veces el que dos veces e l
esto es exactamente lo mismo que www1
que tres veces w y aquí ya me está
relacionando l con w porque porque va a
ser mucho más fácil visualizarlos y si
yo quisiera despejar de aquí a w
entonces me quedaría que w es
exactamente lo mismo que 2 entre 3 l lo
único que hice fue dividir todo entre 3
ok w es igual a 2 entre 3 l ya está esto
por aquí ahora mi pregunta es cómo nos
va a quedar este patrón ahora si lo
expresamos completamente en términos de
l es decir que esta misma figura la voy
a poner por acá
haremos esta herramienta la voy a poner
para acá
supongamos que es más o menos este de
aquí estas dos figuras son iguales esta
es la misma que está y esta es la misma
que está solamente que esta la voy a
representar en puros términos de él y
por lo tanto de este lado mide el más el
que es dos veces el mientras que de este
lado mide l w
pero el doble o es lo mismo que dos
tercios de l que dos tercios de l
entonces dos tercios de l que es esta
parte de aquí más l es lo mismo que
cinco tercios de el ok y después tenemos
esta figura solamente para que no la
pierdas de vista tenemos algo así algo
así
algo así
y algo así estas dos son iguales ok pero
ahora lo que quiero que veas que tendrá
que cumplir esta región para que lo
llenemos de puros patrones de este
estilo bueno tendremos que ver cuántas
veces cambia de una manera vertical este
patrón a ver cuántas veces cabe y esto
me va a quedar lo mismo que 12 entre y
bueno de largo mide 12 l entonces lo voy
a dividir entre 2 porque son dos veces
este largo dos veces el listo y lo mismo
que seis veces es decir que esta
distancia la puedo dividir en 6 1 2 3 4
5 me van a caber de largo 6 de éstos
ahora vamos a ver cuántos son los que me
caben de ancho y para esto pues voy a
hacer lo mismo voy a dividir 10 entre la
medida que tiene esto de ancho con
respecto a l que son 5 tercios 10 entre
5 tercios y esto es exactamente lo mismo
que usando una ley del sándwich aquí
tenemos un 110 por 3 strange
en 35 lo cuales 6 perfecto también me
caben 6 1 2 3 4 5 y aquí tengo mis 6
también de año es decir que este patrón
esta figura de aquí me va a caber 6 x 6
veces en esta región es decir 6 x 6 36
veces este mosaico me va a caber en esta
región en esta región muy bien
aquí en esta región tengo 36 veces este
patrón pero este patrón está compuesto
de 5 rectángulos recuerdas y si yo lo
que quiero saber es cuántos rectángulos
de l por w me caben en esta región
esencialmente por lo que tenemos que
hacer es multiplicar 36 por 5 36 por 5
lo cual es lo mismo que 30 más 150 es
180 rectángulos rectángulos de l w muy
bien y esta es mi respuesta que por
cierto es el inciso y ya está tenemos
aquí el último problema de este examen
número 3 en el siguiente vídeo
empezaremos el examen número 4 hasta la
próxima